i'm absolutely gutted i'm gutted to go
i
you know it's been hard but i wanted
longer it's the end of the road for
melanie c on dancing with the stars well
i'm going to say that the couple i'd
like to save is olivia and
following greece night fans bid farewell
to the spice girls star and her pro
partner gleb marking one of the most
surprising and difficult eliminations in
recent dancing with the stars history
ah
this is a tough one america what have
you done this is hard extremely hard
neither of you deserve to be in this i
tell you this
it's legit it's legit stuff like people
gotta vote you know like people gotta
vote i i think you did an amazing job et
spoke with the pair after the show and
melanie was still feeling emotional
about the unexpected turn of events
mel c girl i had you in the final i had
you winning this thing
and i
i thought i could see tears in your eyes
there and my heart just goes out to you
because you're so incredible what was it
like standing on stage after you two
heard your names called you made me cry
now
um
you know what i've been saying to
everybody look somebody's gotta go you
know and
everybody works so hard and everybody
every week produces great dances the
pair ended up in the bottom two
alongside olivia jade and val and fans
were shocked given that both contestants
totally crushed it during their quick
step and foxtrot
[Music]
now
[Music]
both gleb and melanie and olivia and val
earned impressive scores four nines for
a total of 36 out of 40. but after the
judges were split on who should go home
head judge len goodman cast his deciding
vote and that was that well i'm going to
say that the couple i'd like to save is
olivia and olivia
are safe oh it was honestly really scary
and it put into perspective how much i
love being here i don't think mel
deserved to go home at all i don't think
anybody in this competition deserves to
go home because everybody works so hard
but obviously that's just how the cookie
crumbles and that's the nature of this
show so it sucks i was like praying like
i was like counting in my head like one
two three
and the couple who say
melanine like i was saying it in my head
i was saying it in my head i was like
planned
please
please save us save us cause
you know i've made a friend for life and
i wanted to stay in the competition i i
was already thinking like we're going
all the way all the way till the end mel
how has this competition changed you i
feel really proud of myself and i've
been petrified of going on that dance
floor of making mistakes
and letting people down but i did it you
know i went out there and i did i don't
feel i did as well as i could have done
um and you know what i'm gonna get back
on stage i think i need to go and maybe
write some songs and do some singing
will you be writing songs about the
emotions this experience has brought up
go with something new to inspire you and
this has definitely been an experience
like no other some of it good
some of it not so good so um yeah i will
put it into my work
[Music]
you